this video is brought to you by
Squarespace whether you need a domain
website or online store make it with
Squarespace
[Music]
hey wisecrack Jerrod here it all started
when someone at the office said Jerrod
you got to watch the boss baby
so I did and then perhaps reluctantly we
covered it on our movie podcast show me
the meaning and yes shameless plug
check it out using the link in the
description and let me tell you
something odd happens to you when you
spend hours thinking about the boss baby
soon it became a semi ironic obsession
and then after got nominated for an
Oscar we said we have to do a video on
the boss baby so we're gonna do
something a little different today it's
not that the boss baby is a deliberate
and nuanced exploration of childhood
psychology it's more holy this movie
accidentally shows us how the way we
currently think about love is not only
ruining us but our future children so if
you thought the tide pod challenge was
bad for kids strap in for this wisecrack
edition on the boss baby and as always
and if you care spoilers ahead let's
start with a recap tim is living a
perfect childhood with his family it's
nothing but imaginary adventures and
expensively licensed lullabies until the
baby shows up suddenly Tim's parents
need to spread the love around and Tim
finds himself struggling with not being
the center of attention
Tim learns that this is no ordinary baby
it's an oscar-nominated boss baby it can
talk hold meetings and eat solid food at
first Tim tries to expose the babies
bossy ways making a B suited baby might
freak his parents out enough that they I
don't know throw the baby away or
something
but the boss baby isn't going out like
that and outwits him at every turn
Tim learns the baby is only around to
foil a puppy cows mysterious new puppy
that threatens to make babies obsolete
somehow so he agrees to help Tim and the
oscar-nominated boss baby sneak into
puppy code to conduct some corporate
espionage their madcap adventure goes
off the rails and they end up in Las
Vegas saving their parents from a rocket
ship with the help of a tidal wave of
puppies it's weird so what's the movie
really about well the short answer is
easy
[Music]
no it's about love Tim wants his parents
love the boss baby wants to win the
market share of love back from those
gosh dang puppies and the villain wants
to steal love away from babies no one
ever wants a baby ever ever again it all
comes back to love in the end Tim and
the boss baby have a delightful reunion
when they realized that love is not a
finite resource there's enough for
everyone now that's a nice message and
all but anyone who's ever had a high
school crush knows we don't always get
the love we want now I know who cares a
silly Kids movie has a reductive view on
love so what well this view on love
isn't just simplistic some might call it
dangerous like known weirdo and
everyone's second favorite psychoanalyst
Jacques Lacan one of lakhan's
fundamental ideas is the idea of lack in
short Lacan says that we spend our lives
looking for meaning unity and peace but
those aren't real things we're never
going to find them and the desperate
search for them is what makes people
neurotic we develop social and
psychological disorders to cope with the
fact that despite how badly we want life
to be perfect it never will be and it's
this lack that defines tim's struggle in
the film for Lacan it all starts with a
child a trauma called the mirror stage
when we're babies we don't really know
what the hell is going on around us but
everything is awesome we're fed we're
taking care of and it's all good but
eventually we see ourselves in a mirror
and realize we're not part of a
comfy-cozy world but just one little
being in a giant world that realization
hurts it's when we realize we're on our
own
we see this phenomena play out in boss
baby too albeit a little differently Tim
is naive to the fact that the world
doesn't cater to his every need until
the boss baby shows up and he is
traumatized suddenly the world isn't all
about Tim his parents only have a finite
amount of love to give
Mamas dad don't even know you they love
me oh yeah
do the math kid there's only so much
love to go around
it's like these beads you used to have
all your parents love all their time all
their attention you had all the beads
but then I came along babies take up a
lot of time they need a lot of attention
they get all the moms we could share you
obviously didn't go to business school
this theory that there isn't enough love
for everyone is the foundation of every
oscar-nominated choice the boss baby
makes Tim tries to live with the baby
but he can't it consult so he tries to
expose him so his parents will get rid
of him no dice
he even jumps over a train and sneaks
onto an Elvis themed flight to Vegas all
to make this baby go away
why because the baby interrupted his
notion of how love works life was good
life was perfect but as I drifted off to
sleep something my parents said got me
thinking where do babies come from no
matter how much this feeling of having
your ideal reality shattered may suck
it's an essential stage of human
development however instead of having
Tim move past this difficult stage the
film doubles down on his childish
fantasy suggesting that love is in fact
infinite tim writes a letter to the boss
baby saying that there's plenty of love
for both of them as long as they have
each other it's heartwarming but for
lacan desire for love or anything else
is insatiable because the world will
never be perfect it's the inevitable
outcome of lack will never have the
flawless complete life we want so we
focus on specific things as objects of
desires or an individual problems as the
source of our suffering in other words
Tim's idea that love can or should be
infinite is a fantasy and boy does Tim
love fantasy throughout the movie we see
him creating fantasies to represent the
world around him he uses those fantasies
to entertain himself to show his
feelings and a grapple with how love
works in the end we learned the whole
movie is just a story adult him as
relaying to his daughter to prepare her
for a sibling on the way well sweetie
that's how I remember it
but you know what I found out what
there's plenty of
for everyone Lacan might say this poses
a few issues by creating this bizarre
narrative about a ruthless corporate
baby who threatens to close on all the
market share of love and his family unit
Tim is essentially demonizing his little
brother the deal with the fact that love
is not in fact infinite but whether
finite or not we're always going to want
more and we'll never get all the love we
want this targeting of a single cause
for all our problems is something that
Lakhani and scholars and also regular
people refer to as scapegoating in the
case of the family we developed neuroses
to cope with the feelings of isolation
that start with the mirror stage or we
fabricate a story about a giant
corporation of babies to justify hating
our little brother we see the same thing
happen with the villain Francis Francis
formerly super colossal big fat boss
baby
he becomes an evil psychopath and tries
to steal love from all babies because
his fantasy of staying a baby forever is
taken away from him and he blames all
other babies this is what happens when
we expect a perfect world and don't get
what we want we act like babies but not
necessarily the oscar-nominated kind and
then Tim does quite possibly the most
irresponsible thing ever he passes his
fantasy and all the neurotic baggage
that comes with it on to his daughter
inundating your daughter with the idea
that your basic desires will always be
fulfilled is well not great that will
probably lead to some issues down the
line like whatever happened to this kid
[Music]
so what's the deal is it just that love
is another one of the many things were
programmed to want but doomed to never
get enough of
not so fast Lacan might say there is in
fact a secret way around the problem of
love and fantasy and it's also hidden in
the oscar-nominated story of the boss
baby what the movies ending gets right
is that the love between the brothers is
the healthiest relationship we see in
the movie but that's not because love is
infinite
instead it's because love depends on
showing us how much we're missing you
Raven know it's like to be part of a
family and you don't know what it's like
to have a job Lacan famously referred to
love as to give what one does not have
when we love someone we reflect their
lack back to them we show them what they
are missing and for Lacan that
confrontation with lack is far more
psychologically curative than covering
over our desires with fantasies and
scapegoats
if we accept that definition of love
it's hard to argue that the brothers
don't live up to it from the very
beginning their position not just as
opposites but as complementary boss baby
is practical but Tim is a dreamer the
boss baby writes memos Tim takes action
tim has experienced love and values it
immensely boss baby has never been loved
and isn't too worried about it
I may look like a baby but I was born
all grown up he never had someone to
love you well they can't miss what you
never had they each cover the others
flaws and reflect them back to each
other in a way that helps them both grow
and save the day it's the boss baby's
motivational skills that keeps him on
the bike once he loses the training
wheels a path to success is not a
straight line Templeton but rather a
wild ride and it's Tim's imagination
that allows them to defeat Francis
Francis in the end by showing the other
what they're missing and embodying those
values they help each other grow into
more well-rounded and healthy
individuals for lacan love isn't meant
to fill in the gaps we fill in our lives
the attempt to make life perfect is
exactly what leads to neuroses and
pathology and all kinds of other messy
things instead love shows us what we're
missing and makes it okay because we see
what is missing in someone else maybe it
seems like we're going a little
overboard on a movie about a baby who is
somehow paradoxically a boss but this is
an important
lesson real life is full of
disappointment and few if any things
live up to the world we imagine but
that's no reason to get depressed all
you need to do is realize that things
aren't going to be perfect not everyone
gets nominated for an Oscar and once you
see that imperfection reflected in the
world around you it's really not so bad
thanks wisecrack and before you go want
to be a real boss use Squarespace to
design your next website it's so easy a
baby can do it use the offer code
wisecrack get tempers off your first
purchase of a website or domain today
don't know how to code not a problem
Squarespace is all-in-one platform and
gorgeous designer templates make it a
cinch to build an eye-catching website
for your project or business and with
award-winning 24/7 customer support help
is never more than a phone call away and
on over to Squarespace com for your free
trial and when you're ready to launch
go to squarespace.com slash wisecrack
and use the offer code wisecrack to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain thanks for watching guys
remember to hit the subscribe button and
ring that Bell catch y'all next time
peace
[Music]